[Music]
[Applause]
I'm a knight Mozilla open news fellow
and I work at m'hidi and inter news
Kenya I'm gonna be talking about
teleportation as soon as my slide starts
right so my title is mapping 101 mapping
127 point 0.001 how to teleport and find
home and it's kind of about mapping 101
because I work on open source crisis
maps but it's also a little bit about
transporting yourself in other ways
other than that so when we think of
teleportation we think about science
fiction right we think of Star Trek we
think of Nightcrawler and x-men right
but teleportation has a close
relationship to transportation right
it's just breaking things into bits or
qubits transporting them across a
landscape and recomposing them in a new
space and I was thinking about this a
lot because I was toggling between New
York and Nairobi and thinking about what
home meant in those places and how the
topography changes but also the telling
networking capabilities change and how
that affects my conception of what home
is in those different places
so here's traffic right traffic is a way
of transporting yourself and maybe in
Nairobi there's a problem percent
probability of lions and in Time Square
there's no 10% probability of lions so
the difference isn't that much traffic
sucks
everywhere traffic sucks everywhere but
think about network traffic right let
down load speeds the availability of
apps at those speeds think about what
your experiences on the Internet and how
different it is in places where the
internet is slower right what is your
home like in places where the internet
it downloads videos like that and this
have to needle points in my home I have
there's no place like localhost and I
have a Kanye West tweet about Persian
rugs and cherub imagery and what the
system is that I define home according
to the Internet right my my loving
memorials and my home are about the
internet and memes and teleportation
itself kind of has you know similar
route words to telecommunications and
transportation so it makes sense but
that kind of network activity that
connectivity between point a and point B
the relationship is established in those
pseudo similar route words so there's
three ways to teleport right you can do
at the scientific way with the qubits
and the decomposing like the
netherlander scientist so you can do it
the geographic way by transporting
yourself across space so you can do it
the technological way like globe genie
or you can kind of search
something and go via google maps to that
new place if you take like a Fineman
path integral theorem is like been
reduced significantly you can see that
it's usually about time it's about space
it's about place which is what we think
about when we think about maps right
we're breaking we're flattening things
to a 2d and right so a collapsing time
the first type of map you're gonna see
here is shows internet speeds you don't
really need to know what it means
despite the red presentation you saw
before red in this case is bad right so
Africa not doing so well not doing so
hot in terms of internet speeds what
about in terms of disconnection your
disconnection likelihood also bad bad
Africa it's not very not doing very well
but we also want you to notice is if we
still break this down according to
political boundaries that we establish
in a regular map making right it's not
any different despite the fact that
you're talking about the data you're
plotting is about connectivity in a
different medium so social media we
often you know connect ourselves to
places based on our ability to contact
our friends based on our ability to
network with them and in some places
those connectivity you know channels are
throttled by your government or by other
thing so in Russia keyd this is how
we've dealt with this right we develop
this product called the brick that
Liao's you to spin up internet anywhere
it's about the size of a cell phone and
it connects to a bunch of sensors so you
can deploy it in the field and collect
sensor data about your environment right
we also do this by private network so
VPN I would throw my IP address in
different places to access faster
internet but we also developed
crowdsourcing services like crowd mapped
and ro Shahidi platform which collects
data from dumb phones so you don't have
to depend on an internet connectivity to
collect data about your space we also do
it by proxy pinging is an app that was
developed after the Westgate Mall
attacks in order to ping your network to
see where your family members are and
then crisis net also aggregates a lot of
social media data into one unified API
so you can ping it to find out
authoritative information about crises
happening all over the world and what I
want you to notice about this is this is
an example of a solar map that breaks
down with all the many-worlds
possibilities of what could have
happened after 1777 you know it's a
frontier future it was originally a Jif
but now it's just a static image so um
but what I want you to notice about this
is that we haven't really changed our
mapping of how we fractal eyes space how
we break it down into frontiers right
we're still a scratch
to political boundaries to economic you
know limitations we haven't changed it
despite the fact that the structure of
the architecture of the Internet is
different so I started with a kanye west
suite I'm going to close at the Kanye
West quote the world as a whole is fugly
the internet is fugly too but I'm not in
the construction business and if you can
ignore the non-sequitur of that
statement and just look at the Reds
right he's talking about the world in
the internet also deferring the
construction of it but what's
interesting about this conference is
that we are constructors right and if
you're gonna establish those kind of
imperialistic boundaries you need to
think about the landscape you're
imparting to posterity and what that
might mean for the future so um right so
my name is really a douche et thank you
for listening